president Trump established a new office
in the White House to create
partnerships between the government and
faith-based groups it's part of an
executive order called the White House
faith an opportunity initiative that
Trump signed today during a National Day
of Prayer ceremony we are proud of our
religious heritage and as president I
will always protect religious liberty
the faith initiative will help design
new policies that recognize the vital
role of faith in our families our
communities and our great country we
take this step because we know that in
solving the many many problems and our
great challenges faith is more powerful
than government and nothing is more
powerful than God Trump may often sound
like the most Pro faith president modern
times but oh gosh there's still much to
do here's to discuss Reverend Johnny
Moore spokesperson for the president's
informal evangelical advisory group well
it was a it was a hot day and the
outside of the White House there a lot
of evangelical Christians people were
stunned like how do you guys support
Donald Trump me look married three times
you know all the deals now it's stormy
Daniels why does this president speak to
the evangelical base today given what's
happened well to the religious liberty
community I mean he's a total hero but
that's what's what he's done I mean this
executive order this year was part two
you know last year at this very National
Day of Prayer he ordered basically an
audit of the entire federal government
to determine every single example where
religious liberty was being violated
with the whole cabinet sitting there and
this year he's saying you know we've
cleaned all that up we you know there's
a whistleblower element of this
executive order he's saying to the
public you see a problem tell us about
it saying oh now we got all that settled
so how can we partner together as a
faith community in doing it in the Rose
Garden steps out of the Oval Office was
a powerful symbolic image yes
symbolically I mean just seeing it his
words who in everything that's going on
in swirling around him did did any of
you get together do pray regularly with
him
do you yeah we pray with the
administration you know all the time we
pray with him we pray with others I mean
you know the other day a reporter asked
me is it true that there's like an
evangelical in the White House every day
and I said it's probably like 25 every
day you know at least 10 or 12 of them
in the West Wing and a bunch of them on
the cabinet as well I mean this is a
faith friendly administration policy
where their words well although you know
he said who's gonna help the little
sister the poor contraception mandate
I'm gonna get rid of that but it's not
we they're still litigating that so he
hasn't given the release I mean look
Congress has to do some of this stuff
but couldn't he with an executive order
address that issue and then probably
head to the court the fact is that the
Obama administration had so obsessively
deconstructed religious liberty across
the federal government I mean it took
him a whole year to sort of untie all of
this you know and I think the Little
Sisters of the Poor are just they're
gonna fight this to the to the very end
because they were taken advantage of but
they want president Trump's gonna get in
there and make sure that that doesn't
happen that they're mandating
contraception coverage to these nuns a
hundred percent of the time President
Trump has demonstrated that he is
entirely supportive of religious
liberties the most Pro religious liberty
president that we've had and you know I
think when it's when it's all said and
done as we've seen again and again and
again the proof will be in the policy
that's what it'll be you know and it is
the National Day of Prayer - I mean this
is amazing and for eight years President
Obama had a private celebration he
issued proclamations this was a powerful
ceremony it's great to see you and we're
praying right along with you guys today
thank you